all right
i'm so excited
so excited happy thursday everyone what
a great show we have tonight
but we always have a great show don't we
it's as regular as me after eating seven
bran muffins
so this monologue is about risk there
are people who take genuine risks
and there are others who only pretend
yeah she's a real nelson mandela
well more like nelson from the simpsons
anyway when we think of risk we usually
think of young edgy types taking chances
daredevils soldiers seal teams someone
who will eat a bowl of chili before
boarding a five-hour flight that's cat
and the opposite of risk
the old the retired sitting on the
veranda sipping arnold palmer's while
buying gold and silver from william
devane
but now it's reversed the old are the
new young and the young are the new old
cancel culture has created a benjamin
button effect in terms of behavior of
older generations as we get older we're
taking more risks and it's the younger
ones who aren't
here's john cleese talking about humor
and risk-taking
a lot of comedians now uh are sitting
there and when they think of somebody
something could i get away with that i
don't think so so and so i got into
trouble and he said that or she said
that you see what i mean and that's the
death of creativity if you're worried
about offending people and constantly
thinking of that you are not going to be
very creative so i think it has a
disastrous effect hmm monty python in
comedy it's the older guys battling the
safe spacers whether it's cleese or
ricky gervais david spade colin quinn
nick depaolo dennis miller rogan
chappelle jim brewer you also see jk
rowling johnny rotten eric clapton john
waters van morrison these are old people
taking actual risks against the group
speak of wokism
and then there's one other guy leading
the pack and who could that be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
i hate it when the producers slip that
in
you guys
really stop it
so
these old farts are standing up to the
mob just like frankenstein's monster
except instead of facing pitchforks it's
smartphones again it's not the young
it's the old maybe it's because of
wisdom or maybe it's relief factor
but i prefer to call it balls
meanwhile it's the young who must have
every whim catered to them like a bride
on their wedding day
last night a mini nap minneapolis club
called first avenue canceled a show by
dave chappelle citing public outcry
meaning they got a silly letter from
some purple-haired gnome with a bmi of
158.
the club caved to the most low-risk
nonsense a change.org petition demanding
not to platform transphobe dave
chappelle the petition reads chappelle
has a record of being dangerous to trans
people and first ave has a duty to
protect the community chapel's actions
uphold a violent heteronormative culture
and directly violate first avenue's code
of conduct
well if that statement was any more full
of crap it would be the floor backstage
at the westminster kennel club
and
does chappelle have a record of being
dangerous to trans people i mean they're
talking like they just found caitlyn
jenner's bones in a crawl space under
his house
but chappelle is being dangerous he
speaks his mind that's real risk these
days in the face of the faceless mob he
is the daredevil unlike anyone who signs
that petition meanwhile the man who
tried to murder him in l.a is charged
with misdemeanors
but when you think men can give birth
that everything is backwards
so these delicate daffodils claim they
must be protected imitating real people
at real risk just like aoc in her
invisible handcuffs
so why not just skip the damn show how
hard is that
and even if they went the only danger
they face is that there's not enough
room for their emotional support dogs
so let's be frank
simply claiming you're trans or
non-binary it's not risky it's not
illegal that's for sure you get double
the movie rolls and double the bathrooms
and the media embraces you like the new
flavor of the intersectional ice cream
try our new ginger with nuts
in the old days
in the old days young people did risky
things now they just write petitions
throw public tantrums and pick a pronoun
for their twitter bio
they were only strong in a large group
wearing a mask and carrying a bike lock
but that petition worked it got
chappelle booted first avenue states we
believe in the diverse voices and the
freedom of artistic expression but in
honoring that
we lost sight of the impact this would
have
we know there are some who will not
agree with this decision you are welcome
to send feedback all right so here's
some feedback i hope your club goes
under like one of ted kennedy's dates
yeah you believe in the freedom of
expression only if patton oswalt played
there and put everyone to sleep
so that's my theory old people have now
become the young people and young people
the old
this feels like the right time for a
skit
hey grandma just calling to make sure
you're staying inside and double masking
just in case don't be
grandpa
such
i are going out tonight i can't rip
shots of tequila with the mask on
grandma those words are violence plus
drinking tequila is cultural
appropriation why don't you just stay
inside eat some soup and watch jeopardy
like we are
yeah okay boomer why don't you save us a
table at the early bird special actually
you know what never mind grandma and i
gotta go it's hot girl summer and i'm
taking pictures for her only fans
so as the young prefer security the old
are out taking risks they're having fun
saying what they want
larry kudlow just asked me to go hang
gliding
in the nude
again again
now maybe the old have less to lose or a
lot more money or maybe it's just hard
to be afraid of a guy with
the young people though demand safety
and conformity remember this famous
picture white blm protesters surrounding
a woman at brunch demanding she raise
her fist that's as conformist and
risk-free as it gets
and that's a lot of people these days
who embrace the opposite of risk which
is might makes right
why do they join the mob maybe they're
scared of the mob turning on them or
they're just doing what they think is
popular like everyone that pretends to
like npr
or
maybe they like the power and the
attention
or maybe they suck
in the old days you'd say those who
can't do teach now it's those who can't
do cancel those who can
either way it's obvious how they never
make these public demands one-on-one
it's always in packs because there's
safety in numbers even if those numbers
are a bunch of zeroes
she'll leave her kids in the car for a
glass of pinot noir rar fox news anchor
julie bader
his name is cass because he's always on
the money former white house national
security council aide cash patel
[Applause]
he leaves women in stitches because his
jokes make them slash their wrists
she's like a stick skinny sharp and your
mom says leave her outside yeah
fox news contributor cat tip
[Music]
really it's good to see that you made it
here in one piece i did yeah yeah it's
been a rough week yeah been a rough week
waking up in different places not sure
where you are
stuff like that well cat's couch i know
where that is within her living room
she was welcome to tell you yeah i never
made it back to the hotels um and you
are while you're uh going on these
drunken binges
you're also raising young people
that makes you a hero
are you raising them to take risks
uh
a little bit but i'm not ways raising
like whiny woke brats that's what i want
to say regarding this uh chappelle thing
which is absolutely ridiculous 150 000
uh tickets in fact no 1500 people bought
tickets 150 protested right there you go
so you got one percent who actually
cared about this and and that's your way
of doing it instead of you know
complaining just don't go or maybe show
up cat call and you know the last time
somebody stormed the stage dave
chappelle show that went well yeah so
maybe do that and and maybe when's your
next show not not after you just told
people to run up on stage
um
those people that signed the petition
they weren't even buying tickets i mean
it's not like they would they matter the
club see i think the story here is that
the club is cowardly they're just
incredible what a bunch of losers
especially when you see the rebound
thank you
i like getting applause because it eats
into cat's time
sorry cash
cash what what you said oh no for
i don't know
i feel like i got nothing to add to this
chappelle conversation why
uh i kind of lost respect for him when
mayor bowser and dc invited him out for
his birthday party and they and mayor
bowser at the time had made everyone
wear masks starting the next morning
and everybody was like what the f and so
now people are complaining about his
show getting cancelled i mean i really
just don't give
you do the show if you have a pair of
balls like who cares stand outside and
do it well he did actually do the show
he moved to another another venue that's
an interesting opinion you're mad at him
because he wore a mask in dc because i
wasn't i wasn't allowed to
i see
what do you think about my theory that
young people are now old people and old
people are now young people well i'm
going to stump you so what are like
middle people like you
thank you
well i think i'm old by comparison i
mean i'm in my early 40s so
i mean the good thing about me
i thankfully have my mother's genetics
and indian people never age so i'm gonna
just stay young but you call me old so i
don't know are we gonna fight now yes
i would win
probably would i know karate i'm gonna
bring her in though i'm taking
it like it when you always kids always
said i know karate
that's the parents i know karate and
then you didn't and karate never worked
joe it never worked you always got your
ass kicked um you claim to be comedian
we've seen you some evidence
um feel free to comment on the chappelle
thing sure you can trash this whole
segment like kash patel just did
but that's what they want i can relate
i i have had venues uh cancel shows of
mine but that was due to low ticket
sales
yeah
i was able to move it to the parking lot
we had a good time and i enjoyed the
tips from validating people's parking
julie made a good point that it was a
hundred and fifty or so people it's an
online petition right anybody can do it
you can't even crumple it up yeah
so pathetic so these venues i don't know
why they book comedy because they could
spare themselves having to make these
groveling up we are so the harm that
it's it didn't cause anybody harm and
what it did was it pissed off a bunch of
crybabies who have tremendous egos
because if you don't want to go to the
show it's very simple don't go yeah
that's not enough they want to make it
so no one else can go
and
comedy is supposed to be upsetting and
disturbing it's supposed to violate your
expectations that's what makes people
laugh and the funniest comics out there
now people like andrew schultz and tim
dillon and kyle dunnigan they're really
funny and they say some things that
sometimes you laugh because you just
don't know what else to do you know um
it's i think it's i said this on the
five it's a compliment when you're
finally being roasted
and i think that you're that you're now
accepted as part of society but i want
to before i go to cat uh one last
question to you
what happened why can't the club eat
eat the cost of this like isn't there a
contract involved
you know well i think the the cost is a
an emotional cost for the club that
they've invested in being these
the idea that i mean no but i mean if
you get a contract i mean look i'm going
to speak in florida this weekend and if
somebody and so i you know
i'm gonna keep the money
yeah you know it's like that should be
the deal it's like if you cancel me sure
i'm keeping the money
right it's not
it's
i do yeah it's not like um
it's not like a water main broke in the
venue exactly
there's no act of god clause that says
are you
well then you don't have to pay exactly
cats welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me yeah
excellent uh acting uh playing both a
young and an old woman in the same skit
thank you i am very talented you are
extremely talented uh
so what would you
what do you think of that theory uh do
you believe it or what or would you
rather address the chappelle story okay
thank you for giving me a choice
um yeah i'm pro-choice yes there's
something to it
i think that there's something to it i
also just think that the reality of is
it is of it all of it is that there's no
such thing as a safe space yeah it's
just not possible because
you know these hundred for these 150
people apparently a safe space is one
without dave chappelle in it but dave
chappelle's safe space might be one
where he's you know work doesn't get
cancelled a few hours before or move
somewhere else and now it's all
stressful because everything really is
subjective uh and i so it's impossible
but it's also not good to keep yourself
in your comfort zone all the time
because then you don't learn anything
new you don't grow as a person and also
safe stuff honestly is boring
it is oh
i don't know
but there you can create safe
environments to do dangerous things yeah
i think it's important that you do yes
excellent
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else